i think he did a lot an incredible
amount he got a lot more people
engaged in politics
[Music]
america has never been so deeply divided
show us the proof that we're asking for
and no one seems to be willing to do
that in the 2020 election 74 million
people voted for donald trump
the second highest in history after joe
biden
so since he lost his re-election
campaign what's going to happen
to trumpism
[Applause]
these politicians are not in charge they
govern
at the consent of the people
many newly elected republicans have been
voted in
on a pro-trump ticket so even though
donald trump
isn't in office trumpism hasn't gone
anywhere
and supporters of the former president
will still expect
their values to be represented by
politicians
to lump everybody together into one
category and say all 75 million people
that supported trump or voted for trump
you're terrible people and that that is
a um that's a scary thing too
despite losing some support from white
evangelical christians in the 2020
election
president trump still convinced an
overwhelming majority of them
75 percent he also won a majority
67 percent of white working class voters
so when it comes to issues of abortion
gun control
safety in america no problem with this
or simply the interests of white
working-class voters
president biden will have to tread
carefully to keep a divided nation
together there's 74 million of us we're
not going away we need to find out who
our leader is
the initial movement would be 2022
is primary the heck out of these people
that are against trump
and trumpism so to speak
and could trumpism live on through one
of donald trump's own children
ivanka and donald jr particularly are
influential in their own right
we have to send a resounding message
that patriotism is alive
and well in georgia so it's fair to say
for as long as there's still trump
family members around
trumpism isn't going anywhere
[Music]
not everyone agrees though the capital
riots in january 2021
changed some staunch supporters minds
when i arrived in washington this
morning i fully intended to object to
the certification of the electoral votes
however the events that have transpired
today have forced me to reconsider
we've had a hell of a journey i hate it
then this way from my point of view he's
been a consequential president
but today all i can say is
uh count me out enough is enough
research done after the capitol hill
riots
showed the number of trump supporters
that think he's done a bad job
has doubled from 10 to 20 percent
but the overwhelming majority of
republican-leaning voters
still agree even after the riot that
donald trump
probably or definitely won the 2020
election
despite overwhelming evidence to the
country
there's a big movement of leaving the
republican party or
i don't know ag party the patriotic
party
[Music]
because the the republican party um
basically has left us
they they truly don't support him
[Music]
we don't exactly know who q is okay
q is not one person for a smaller more
extreme
subsection of donald trump supporters
those who believe the discredited q and
on conspiracy theory
support is dwindling what q and on
supporters believe
is that donald trump is fighting a satan
worshiping
pedophile ring led by hillary clinton
youtube cues playing save the world
and then an individual known as q is a
mystery trump official
with q clearance who posts classified
information
online for his supporters i am 100
behind cue he's working for the
president he's working for our country
q is a bunch of people they're on the
inside they're the good guys
q and on supporters have been split over
the riots with many disassociating
themselves from the violence
and with others calling thought renewed
action
as people were trying to figure out what
was going on after the election where q
didn't weigh in when people in those
networks were starting to despair
they were saying you know it was an op
the whole time we got played
you know the the trump wasn't as
powerful as he had said he was they were
disappointed that there hadn't been mass
arrests
despite the disillusionment many q anon
supporters attended the riot
on january the 6th their support may
simply transition
to something equally extreme rather than
dissipate altogether
now that these groups have met each
other now that they've been through a
moment together i often think about
moments like
uh what we saw at the capitol as a as a
crucible the relationships that they
forge
usually when we see a movement resort to
violence
it's really hard to get
them to uh see
other institutional paths to social
change
yeah i don't i don't subscribe to any of
that it's it's conspiracy theory it's
just
it's way out left there they're hurting
uh the trump cause in my opinion or you
know moving forward or at least
if there's some sort of party um that he
creates or
or maybe i don't know maybe the
republican party
will go away because
[Music]
i think they they too have forgotten why
they're in office and
and who they're fighting for
you